[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
soyez les bienvenus dans ça vous regarde
à la une ce soir la judiciarisation de
la crise sanitaire à peine les annonces
présidentielles dévoilé hier soir des
perquisitions ont eu lieu ce matin au
domicile de plusieurs ministres et ex
ministre olivier ferrand edouard
philippe agnès buzyn et si bête
n'diaye que leur reproche-t-on
précisément sur quoi portent les
plaintes devant la cour de justice de la
république et le risque pénal le risque
pénal peut-il dissuader les élus à se
lancer en politique qu'ovide quand la
justice s'en mêle c'est le thème de
notre grand débat ce soir on va parler
aussi de la jeunesse dans cette crise
sanitaire c'est dur d'avoir 20 ans a
reconnu hier le président de la
république de couvre-feu dans les
grandes villes est un coup de massue
supplémentaire pour les plus jeunes
études en pointillés avenir
professionnel boucher peut-on parler
d'une jeunesse sacrifiée
on en parlera dans un décryptage dans la
deuxième partie de cette émission sans
oublier bien sûr la chronique de thomas
des prêts il a promené sa caméra ils
sont dix groupes savoir ce que pensaient
les députés de ces couvre-feu dans huit
métropoles et dans tout les deux ans ce
sera dans ma journée à l'assemblée voilà
pour le programme
c'est parti à sec sévère n'oubliez pas
tout de suite le grand débat
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs bonsoir anne john t
merci d'être là vous êtes député la
république en marche des français de
l'étranger porte-parole du groupe
majoritaire à l'assemblée nationale vous
débattez ce soir avec charles de courson
bonsoir mon choix merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation vous êtes député à
liberté et territoires de la marne et en
tant que parlementaire vous êtes aussi
juge titulaire au sein de la cour de
justice de la république jugé lui vous
allez nous nous expliquer tout cela
c'est là la cour qui est compétente pour
juger les membres du gouvernement enfin
bonsoir maître fabrice di vizio il merci
d'être sur ce plateau vous êtes avocat
au barreau de paris vous défendez deux
collectifs un collectif de médecins ces
19 c'est son nom est un collectif de
malades victimes du coronavirus et vous
avez porté en leur nom des plaintes
nombreuses quatre ont été retenus
recevable plainte contre edouard
philippe olivier ferrand et agnès buzyn
qui ont débouché d'ailleurs sur les
perquisitions de ce matin perquisition à
leur domicile
on va y revenir dans le détail bonsoir
stéphane bon sens me lacoste qui
m'accompagne comme tous les soirs et qui
va ouvrir ce débat avec son billet si
j'ai bien compris c'est parti
[Musique]
si j'ai bien compris stéphane ce soir
ben si j'ai bien compris myriam
finalement les choses n'ont pas
tellement évolué depuis le moyen-âge
souvenez vous à l'époque quand il y
avait une grosse d'épidémie le premier
réflexe de la société qu'est ce que
c'était de désigner un bouc émissaire
parce qu'il faut reconnaître qu'en cas
de crise le bouc émissaire c'est quand
même très pratiquants y est désigné un
coupable qu'on a connus de tous nos
malheurs
ça permet de se défouler tous ensemble
donc sur la même personne ça resserre
les liens la société alors attention je
vous dis pas que ce n'est pas injuste ce
que je vous dis c'est que ça soulage
alors ce serait qui le bouc émissaire de
nos jours alors pour le corner virus
au départ on avait pensé au tango l'un
mais bon pas très convaincant comme
comme bouc émissaire 1
heureusement on a trouvé beaucoup mieux
depuis le responsable politique mais
bien sûr parce que
responsables politiques il est dispo il
est censé disposer de deux grands
pouvoir d' immense privilège
donc c'est quand même beaucoup plus
crédible que ceux sous pauvre pauvre
pangolin qui est déjà en voie de
disparition
et puis autre avantage c'est que le
pangolin lui est plutôt un animal
sympathique
alors que le responsable politique lui
tout le monde le déteste
et ça c'est bien pour un bouc émissaire
regardez les chiffres qui s'affiche ici
quand on demande aux français ce que
vous pensez que les politiques sont
corrompus ou pas voyez il ya 90 % des
gens qui pensent que les politiques sont
un peu ou beaucoup corrompu donc pas
étonnant que le responsable politique
aujourd'hui c'est finalement le bouc
émissaire idéal celui qu'on va désigner
évidemment là m'a dit que je dise
quelques également pour la crise du
cofide boucs émissaires les politiques
moi ce que je trouve surtout c'est que
aujourd'hui la justice a tendance à
prendre le pas sur la politique si vous
voulez c'est à dire attention le mot
justice à peine 200 saint c'est ça peut
être à la fois une vertu ou une
administration alors si c'était la
justice en tant qu vertus qui prenait
plus de place dans notre société
mais mon dieu mais quelle bonne nouvelle
malheureusement c'est plutôt en ce
moment dans nos sociétés
l'administration judiciaire qui prend de
plus en plus de place alors est ce que
l'administration doit juger comme ça
sanctionner les élus est ce que c'est à
elle en dernier lieu de trancher de la
vie de la société
c'est pas tout à fait ce que pensent
eric dupond moretti c'est même
exactement le contraire de ce qu'ils
pensent
c'est vrai que par les temps qui courent
on est dans la judiciarisation de tous
et que l'époque qui est aussi gier nist
contraint les uns et les autres en
permanence à à chercher des
responsabilités
moi je ne veux pas m'inscrire là dedans
d'abord parce que je pense que ça
profite tout ça profite évidemment aux
extrêmes et je suis convaincu monsieur
alors que que mélenchon et le pen aurait
fait bien mieux qu emmanuel macron
absence d'une certitude absolue voilà un
juin 2020 il faut préciser tout de suite
que ces propos étaient tenus avant qu
eric dupond-moretti soit nommé ministre
c'est bien de le préciser mais moi ce
que je voudrais préciser c'est que
le rassemblement national et la france a
soumise ne se réjouissent pas forcément
de l'intrusion de l'administration
judiciaire la vie politique je trouve
que mélenchon et le pen
eux ce sont des vraies politiques qui se
sont présentés devant les électeurs qui
ont été élus c'est pas des petits
fonctionnaires qui ont obtenu leur
portent pas leur poste par concours et
qui ensuite en grenouille en ont essayé
de gravir des échelons dans la
hiérarchie non ça n'a rien à voir
le fait habiller le réaliser le pen et
mélenchon c'est eux
et en plus ils sont bien passées pour ça
parce que ça puisqu'ils ont ils ont
justement subi cette c1 conditions cette
perquisition de la justice donc c'est
pas sûr qu'ils aient apprécié ce qu'ils
se soient passés ce matin d'ailleurs
dans les premières réactions
coquerel qui est donc eric coquerel
pardon qui est un un élu de la france
insoumise lui tu dénonces justement
cette judiciarisation de la société
quant à gilbert collard qui est un
proche du r'n lui toujours un peu plus
grandiloquents trouve évidemment la
justice aujourd'hui se croyaient tout
permis en s'en prenant aux politiques
donc je veux bien finir par une question
pour rester un peu ouvert donc ma
question ce serait aujourd'hui quand on
est un jeune citoyen de plein de talent
évidemment déjà on est confiné c'est
embêtant mais au-delà de ça quand on
pense à son avenir
est ce qu'on a vraiment intérêt à syndic
s'engager en politique au service de son
pays ou est ce que c'est la meilleure
manière de finir au tribunal
allez vous allez répondre réagir et
ensuite on va re déroulé le dossier dans
le détail je voudrais y imposer les
sourcils
c'est le port gaulin qui vous a choqué
oui pourquoi je raisonne sur mon pays la
france
en 93 je suis jeune député on est en
pleine suite de la crise du sang
contaminé
or à l'époque il n'y a pas d'institution
l'institution c'est la haute cour de
justice
elle est faite pour ne pas fonctionner
elle n'a jamais fonctionné et donc qu'on
dit on ne peut pas continuer comme ça et
donc ont créé la cour de justice de la
république et la première justiciables
ça a été trois ministres qui étaient en
fonction de premier ministre laurent
fabius
edmond hervé genet lifar veille qui
était secrétaire d'état en charge de
cela pourrait très clair vous vous
félicitez aujourd'hui qu'elle les
politiques les responsables
les membres du gouvernement puissent
être bien sûr parce que je suis j'ai
toujours été contre lille responsabilité
ministérielle elle c'est affreux wagner
graal derrière un système des
responsabilités ministérielles mais les
hauts fonctionnaires eux ne sont ils pas
responsables mais ne sont-ils pas sur
l'autorité dès ministres
donc c'est pas possible ça a été un
progrès il fallait réparer responsable
c'est la justice non pas du tout non non
il ya le conseil supérieur de la
magistrature qui est l'organe
disciplinaire une erreur judiciaire et
un certain nombre d'entre eux ils sont
passés voir ont été révoqués les
magistrats voilà ne sont pas exemptés de
responsabilité à john tu es une petite
rédac réaction quand on parle des
responsables politiques bouc émissaire
de cette crise sanitaire à vous elle
vous fait peur cette judiciarisation
elle est pas nouvelle peur ce n'est pas
du tout le temps en revanche la question
soulevée qui est si je suis jeune est ce
que ça me donne envie de rentrer en
politique cet aspect là un peu
effectivement a en tout cas à minima
fait réfléchir il ya d'autres aspects
qui sont si la violence contre les
politiques qui peuvent sans dissuader
mais néanmoins néanmoins je crois que
l'irresponsabilité n'était pas une bonne
chose et je pense que la possibilité
qu'on ait des pouvoirs et des
contre-pouvoirs et pouvoir avoir cette
justice au sens à la fois de la vertu et
de l'organisation qui s'exerce je trouve
ça très bien dans une démocratie alors
je voudrais vous interroger m di vizio
sur le timing
comme on dit en bon français des
perquisitions au lendemain des annonces
présidentielles pour vous ça ne doit pas
étonner c'est la procédure normale
vous imaginez bien que les perquisitions
se sont pas décidés à minuit hier soir
avec des magistrats de la cour de
cassation qui se sont dit tiens emmanuel
macron a parlé nous on a envie d'aller
au restaurant et donc effectivement ce
couvre-feu de l'eau pose un problème et
donc on va aller perquisitionné enfin je
veux dire c'est une offense de le penser
ainsi fait l'institution judiciaire
quand même un avocat n'oserait pas et
c'est à dire effectivement concrètement
que dieu sait si on peut avoir quelques
griefs à l'égard de l'institution
judiciaire mais ce qui est très amusant
si vous voulez c'est que d'habitude on
reproche à l'institution judiciaire
d'aller trop lentement et voilà
qu'aujourd'hui on lui reproche de lait
trop vite vous trouvez qu'il ya une
célérité particulière que vous pouvez
saluer parce que il faut le préciser et
on va voir un sujet qui va nous planter
le décor de manière un peu plus précise
qui est une information judiciaire qui a
été ouverte sur plusieurs ministres
information judiciaire donc y aura des
enquêtes de policiers de police
judiciaire elle a eu lieu cette
information en cette ouverture
d'information juillet on a des
perquisitions en octobre ni octobre
finalement ça va pas si vite c'est
rapide c'est quand même c'est
relativement rapide 6 et relativement
rapide dans une affaire je vais le
préciser différemment dans une affaire
de droit commun ce serait relativement
rapide dans une affaire de cette ampleur
c'est un timing qui somme toute
correspond au timing qui est
habituellement celui de l'institution
judiciaire dans des affaires cette
envergure il faut bien comprendre une
chose importante qu'on oublie peut-être
un peu il ya deux choses importantes
la première c'est que tout le monde a
intérêt à ce que ça évite les ministres
concernés en premier il faut
effectivement peut-être qu'à la fin eh
bien on découvrira que toute cette
affaire finalement nu non grata en
exercice difficile on a intérêt mais on
a intérêt si vous voulez ce que la
vérité soit faite au plus vite pour que
justement si l'innocence en tout cas
s'il ya pas de renvoi devant la cour ça
se sache au plus vite ses premiers mais
je vous pose cette question de la
question du temps de la rapidité et puis
ensuite on va avoir un sujet pour
comprendre dans le détail ce qui est en
train de se jouer on a en mémoire un
certain nombre de grands dossiers où la
responsabilité des élus et des
gouvernants a été engagé vous avez cité
le sang contaminé
on a eu l'impression on pourrait citer
furiani
également même si c'est très différent
mais mais que tout se passe bien après
là on est en plein dans la crise
sanitaire et les ministres sont sous le
coup d'enquêtés
alors qu on l aime pas sortis de cette
crise non sur l' affaire du sang
contaminé vous avez raison mais c'était
la merde mais pourquoi parce qu'il a
déjà fallu créer la cour de justice de
la république
il a fallu élire temps les députés que
les sénateurs que les membres du de la
cour de cassation
il a fallu un point très imparfaite
cédera donc ça a été très long c'est
pour ça que la faute à l'inexistence
d'un système elle a pris beaucoup de
temps et puis vous pouvez avoir des
personnes qui déposent plainte et que
l'instruction est extrêmement compliquée
notamment quand il ya des affaires
étrangères par exemple prenez notre le
prochain dossier que va examiner la
cause de la république c'est la sphère
de ce qu'on appelle la sphère balladur
léotard et c'est qu'ils sont accusés
d'avoir utilisé des pots-de-vin affaire
karachi finances et will affaire de
karachi
bon c'est une affaire internationale
donc le juge d'instruction ont eu
beaucoup de mal à investiguer donc ça
dépend des derrières ces perquisitions
faites les murs on ne sait pas combien
de temps ça va prendre
alors je salue la présence de richard
vers les bons soirs un jeune pêcheur qui
y est chroniqueur dans cette émission et
journaliste correspondant parisien au
quotidien suisse le temps alors on
plonge dans cette affaire qu'est ce
qu'ils reprochaient précisément aux
ministres concernés par cette
information judiciaire on voit ce cas
tout de suite avec clément méric après
les plaintes les perquisitions
edouard philippe agnès buzyn ou encore
olivier ferrand tous ont en commun
d'avoir dû gérer la crise sanitaire
dans le cadre de leurs fonctions
gouvernementales est ce que vous avez
peur d'un éventuel procès pénal non non
non j'ai ma conscience pour moi je sais
ce que j'ai fait sur la centaine de
plaintes pénales déposées contre des
membres du gouvernement seuls neufs
avaient été jugés recevables des
plaintes déposées par des médecins des
patients ou des associations de
personnel soignant les perquisitions de
ce matin sur la suite logique de
l'information judiciaire ouverte début
juillet par la cour de justice de la
république
le délit visé est difficile à établir
abstention volontaire de prévenir un
sinistre
la peine encourue est de deux ans de
prison et 30 mille euros d'un monde s'il
enquête débouche sur un procès il se
tiendra devant la cour de justice de la
république seule habilitée à juger des
actes commis par des ministres dans le
cadre de leurs fonctions
cette enquête s'ajoute à celle ouverte
le 10 juin par le parquet de paris
elles visent des instances
ministérielles ou des responsables
administratifs notamment pour homicides
involontaires ou mise en danger de la
vie d'autrui alors fabrice di vizio vous
êtes l'avocat au coeur de ce dossier je
le disais quatre plaintes ont été jugés
recevables sont donc à l'origine de ces
perquisitions qui défendez vous
précisément déjà moi je défends d'abord
un collectif de médecins qui est
directement concerné vous l'imaginez
bien par la crise et par ses
conséquences au mois de mars dernier
lorsque il était dans l'incapacité de
pouvoir se protéger et protéger leur
passion donc ça c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose je défends une
association de victimes sont corona
victime qui est une association de
victimes du corona virus et qui estime
qu' effectivement les responsabilités
d'autres rechercher la vérité doit être
faite sur les raisons pour lesquelles
est ce que on a vécu un confinement est
ce qu on aurait pu l'éviter est ce que
les masques
il ya eu une abstention volontaire un
moment ce qui est des réponses à des
questions bien vous savez il ya une
commission d'enquêté parlementaire sur
la gestion de la crise sanitaire ici
même à l'assemblée qui se pose ces
questions là
quelle n'est pas plus légitime mais
alors elle n'est pas plus légitime
elle est légitime mais je pense pas
qu'ils aient un concours de légitimité
je pense que chaque institution à sa
légitimité sa vocation propre la
commission parlementaire dans quel
parlementaire à la vocation
constitutionnel de venir établir une
responsabilité que l'on qualifie de
politique c'est à dire de faire la
lumière sur le système et vous avez vu
ces auditions ces auditions transcende
largement la seule personnalité les
seules personnes des ministres concernés
par la plainte
et ensuite vous avez l'institution
judiciaire qui elle va se poser la
question de savoir si il y à eut un
moment donné telle personne dans tel
contexte qui a fait telle chose matin
les enquêteurs cherchaient quoi
précisément de recherche agnès buzyn
selon les loire philippe olivier ferrand
et bien y chercher tout ce qui peut
concourir à la manifestation de la
vérité c'est-à-dire notamment les
échanges de mails dont agnès buzyn pas
la route l'existence c'est ce qu'a eue
il ya eu cet article dans le monde
soula qui a fait vraiment voilà en effet
un effet blast comme on dit dans
l'opinion ou la ministre expliquait
qu'elle avait été alertée dès décembre
par un blog
et puis elle confiait à la journaliste
qui l'interviewait qu'elle avait à ce
moment là dès début janvier alerté le
premier ministre a question c'est les
traces écrites c'est des éventuels mail
charles de courson
8 les commissions d'enquêté
parlementaires c'est un est l'un des
outils dont dispose et parlementaires
pour contrôler l'action du gouvernement
mais aussi de l'administration et si je
puis me permettre bien sûr les
commissions d enquête c'est pas du tout
des juges et non pas à juger mais ils
peuvent saisir la justice
ça a été fait qu'une fois j'étais
rapporteur de cette commission denquête
donc c'était la première fois sur la
sphère liberté que la commission
denquête a saisi au pénal et nous avons
réussi à faire condamner
le président d'air liberté qui avait
détourné 13 millions qui étaient de
l'argent public
alors là le daily mail au sahel et le
scénar et vient pour la première fois
aussi du temps parfois des commission
denquête débouche sur des condamnations
c'est une des îles de céline des
saisines de justice et des procès aux
yeux mais je voudrais savoir qu'est ce
qu'on reproche précisément à ce ministre
oba si vous voulez y à edouard philippe
et à une excuse ans qu'on reproche c'est
à l'aune et à la lumière de ce qu'a dit
agnès buzyn agnès buzyn dit j'ai averti
j'ai envoyé des mails si ce qu'elle dit
est vrai et bien alors il s'agira de se
poser la question de savoir pourquoi est
ce qu'on n'a pas réagi prenant éléments
fait le délit potentiel devant la cour
de justice de la république qui on
arrive jusqu'à ce cas chez vous si je
puis dire c'est l' abstention de
combattre un sinistre wohlhuter de
convaincre il faut le caractère
volontaire il faut que vous réussissiez
enfin que les grands acteurs puissent
prouver qu'il ya eu une abstention
volontaire de combat devrait signer ce
que c'est probable oui c'est probable je
dire si vous voulez classiquement ce qui
se passe si on prend le contexte dans
lequel on se situe si effectivement il
est exact que madame busin a bien averti
le premier ministre
et en fonction de ce qu'elle a écrit
c'est pour ça que la perquisition est
importante en fonction de ce qu'elle a
écrit
si effectivement ce qu'elle a écrit et
suffisamment précis pour que une action
du gouvernement une action du premier
ministre fut nécessaire si cette action
n'a pas eu lieu
et bien alors oui nous serons au jir
cession volontaire parce qu'il faut bien
comprendre que la notion d' abstention
volontaire elle se mesure à l'aune de la
connaissance que nous avions du sinistre
et c'est ici qu'il ya un billet tout le
monde dit depuis le départ mais nous
ignorions ce qui allait se passer
oui peut-être sauf que moi c'est
connaissait que c'est une carotte
incertitudes que dans non dans la graine
est non non non non moi je dis madame
busin dit je savais points alors on va
écouter jean castex et je me donne la
parole
comment on réagit sierre considère que
celle là suffisamment dit pour ouvrir
une instruction quand même jean castex
qui évidemment n'a pas commenté ces
perquisitions étaient interrogés ce
matin en marge de la conférence de
presse qu'il a donnée sur sur les
mesures restrictives mais il a quand
même des fondus ou déviés vers ont
écouté le
sur la confiance que j'accorde à
monsieur olivier verront ici présents
sachez qu'elle est totale outre bien
entendu elle besoin de rappeler que sur
le volet judiciaire que je ne connais
pas il bénéficie d'une totale
présomption d'innocence mais je voudrais
vous faire mesurer à toutes et à tous
mesdames et messieurs la difficulté de
cette crise sanitaire que nous vivons
avait des hauts et des bas depuis
plusieurs mois olivier ferrand est en
fonction depuis plusieurs mois
matin midi soir la nuit le week-end d'un
test devant vous il est toujours au
front toujours offrant toujours nté
c'est la question du du risque pénal et
du poids que ce risque fait peser sur
sur l'action au jour le jour d'un
ministre comme olivier ferrand on peut
on peut bien travailler quand on a cette
épée de damoclès au-dessus de la tête
je le laisserais répondre à ça je pense
que heureusement beaucoup de zones
justice qui fonctionne et qui fait qu'un
certain nombre de personnes là ce sont
des ministres enfin d'autres sont sous
le coup d'une enquête judiciaire si la
vie c'est certainement lourd c'est
certainement pesant sa demande de
l'énergie pour apporter les informations
les réponses aux questions qui nous sont
posées indubitablement et tous ceux qui
sont passés par là peuvent en témoigner
de l'énergie que ça consomme
néanmoins la vie ne s'arrête pas et
heureusement ces personnes là doivent
continuer à poursuivre leur mission il
n'y a aucune raison qu'elle
s'interrompent parce qu'on leur a posé
des questions en revanche voudrais
simplement rajouté une chose et vous
avez prononcé un mot qui m'interpelle
qui me semble très juste
cette crise de l'incertitude
effectivement nous sommes là sur un
accident un accident de l'évolution
microbiologiques à l'accident c'est
l'apparition de ce virus que personne ne
connaissait dont nous ne connaissons pas
aucun microbiologiste aucun
infectiologues
aucun médecin ne savez comment c'est les
choses allaient évoluer et donc la
définition de sa selle que nous n'avons
pas de protocole nous n'avons pas de
réponse est tout à l'heure je vous
expliquer combien même les traitements
ont évolué les traitements au départ que
nous proposions n'était pas du tout ce
que nous propose aujourd'hui car nous
avons appris au fur et à mesure donc
toutes les décisions politiques derrière
ont été prises en mettant en balance
veut pas être raison
quelque chose qui n'est pas prévisible
ce que je vous dit salles de cours sont
fait d'accord non non je suis juge
titulaire donc je ne voyais pas quoi
dire quoi que ce soit sur le fond
simplement qu' il ya deux types de
recours il ya les recours concernant les
ministres devant la cour de justice de
la république
et il ya les recours concernant les
hauts fonctionnaires qui ne sont pas des
ministres devant les juridictions de
droit commun bien et que ça nous a
toujours posé des problèmes
non non je dis pas ça mais quand vous
avez deux juridictions qu'est ce qui se
passe si elles ont des positions
contradictoires
c'est à dire que prenons l'exemple de la
sphère dont nous parlons supposer que
les juges judiciaires condamne le
directeur de la santé parce qu'il n'a
pas suffi sa manche pour enfin
allaient-elles raison est que la cour de
justice de la république et des
positions inverses
voilà alors je rappelle que ça n'est
jamais arrivé mais ça pourrait arriver
qu'on peut faire appel de la décision de
la cour de justice de la république
devant la cour de cassation s'est pas
encore arrivé mais ça arrivera bien un
jour il aurait forcément une forme de
choc dans l'opinion ces contrats rien
responsable administration sanitaire
soit condamné et passons sa tutelle ces
poursuites défendu la thèse que il
fallait supprimer la cour de justice de
la république et que les ministres
soient jugés comme les hauts
fonctionnaires devant les juridictions
de droit commun avec temps pour vous
c'est tellement ils font des pressions
une protection comme il y as devant la
cij hier c'est à dire commission des
requêtes puis commission d'aller on va
revenir là dessus juste après mais sur
le risque pénal je voudrais quand même
vous faire réécouter cette archive
c'était sur le plateau de bfmtv
c'était philippe de villiers qui
rapportait des propos que lui aurait
tenus le chef de l'état concernant
edouard philippe
regardez le 17 mai dernier j'ai eu une
conversation avec emmanuel macron et je
veux aider mais pourquoi il fait ça
edouard philippe
pourquoi on ne confirme pas plus vite et
pourquoi les mêmes qui nous interdisait
les masques ans étaient nécessaires
mais oblige d'arrêter quand ça n'est
plus nécessaire bon pourquoi et m'a dit
philippe il rit gère son risque pénal il
vous a parlé comme ça oui sans problème
comme ça et son premier ministre et m
des visio là bon voilà ce sont des
propos rapportés évidemment à prendre
avec la plus grande des prudences mais
ce risque pénal on a pu le lire on a pu
entendre dire que voilà il a il avait pu
peut-être poser dans la prise de
décision vous savez finement qui aurait
duré l on est dans madame évoquer
quelque chose que je crois fort juste le
risque qu'on qualifie le risque
finalement il existe il n'a pas empêché
de vivre non plus c'est inhérent à
l'action du gouvernement que c'est pas
moins qu'il décide c'est finalement la
loi c'est la constitution qu'il a décidé
qu'à un moment les ministres étaient
justiciables devait répondre de leurs
actes
ces gens lorsqu'ils sont lors qu'ils
acceptent une responsabilité
ministérielle savent que healy à cette
possibilité du risque comme un
parlementaire celle que son immunité
peut être levée et comme on parlait de
responsables si les magistrats
absolument tous citant tout citoyen
comme tout citoyen ce que je veux dire
juste pour terminer sur ce point si vous
permettez le chemin de fer il importe de
souligner quelque chose qu'il faut pas
perdre de vue c'est que jamais vous ne
m'entendrez dire que olivier ferrand
agnès buzyn heures philippe son coupable
de quoi que ce soit il bénéficie d'une
présomption qui à ce stade irf ragab lé
quai d'une présomption d'innocence et il
faut quand même c'est pas parce que la
commission d'instruction a décidé de
mener des perquisitions a décidé de
faire son office
dans le cas d'une alsace jour normal
comme une bonne pression normale nous
sommes dans un cas ni la justice sur la
croisette dire la précède du thé du
point de vue du citoyen moi j'essaie de
me mettre du côté du citoyen l'ancienne
situation était extrêmement choquant les
responsabilités ministérielles
extrêmement choquant donc depuis la loi
de 93
il n'y a pas il ya plus des
responsabilités ministérielles
il ne reste plus que les responsabilités
du président de la république dans
l'exercice de ses fonctions
les responsables de président il ne peut
être incriminé que pour haute trahison
ton bouton vous dire que franchement bon
la nuit lui dans l'exercice de ses
fonctions donc je trouve ça tout à fait
sain et si ce que rapporte philippe de
villiers est exact je ne vois pas le
problème il est tout à fait normal que
vous soyez
voyez par exemple des confié le pilote
l'entreprise vous poser des questions
par exemple pour éviter des accidents du
travail
parce que vous savez que si ça tourne
mal votre responsabilité pourrait vous
voyez bien qu'avec la crise sanitaire
vous vous avez des mesures restrictives
qui ont immédiatement des conséquences
économiques terribles donc sans doute un
peu dynamique et dérision qui aille
contre les intérêts de la population
saluons donc le risque pénal n'est l'un
finalement que quelque part pour nous
protéger et tout ça n'est rien sur as
long c'est un risque général et qui est
inhérent à tout citoyen nous avons tous
chaque jour dans nos actions à risque
pénal c'est aussi gérer nice pouvait
prendre des décisions qui ce qui se
révèle être totalement catastrophique
mais le peuple demande justice prenez ce
qui était qui avait été contaminée dans
l' affaire du sang contaminé
enfin vous auriez été contaminés parce
qu'on vous a transfusé vous êtes tombés
malades
très gravement malade et ses comparables
mais c'est non mais c'est le même
problème c'est de dire si une décision
assez le même d'un mini peut entraîner
des catastrophes et qu'on montre que la
décision qu'il a prise n'était pas
éclairé voir qu'il a fait
le généra rue mais d'une grande bâtisse
de dévaluer cela si vous voulez sony
wiesiolek voyez vous moi je c'est
intéressant ce que vous dites parce
qu'on est en pleine crise sanitaire est
on est on est au premier plan les
médecins s'il ya bien une profession qui
gère son risque pénal permanent et qui
pourrait vous dire la même chose que les
ministres c'est les médecins chez moi je
défends des médecins toute la journée et
je suis abasourdi parfois des
condamnations qui sont prononcées par
les juridictions pénales et médecin que
vous défendez ils ont été contaminées
dont certains ont été comptés certains
ont été contaminées mais je défend
également la veuve d'un médecin
généraliste qui effectivement là parce
que on parle ici eux on parle ici des
masques etc
mais je voudrais juste vous souligner un
point c'est qu'on pourrait aussi
s'interroger sur un point c'est qu'on
février par exemple dès février nous
avions les cabinets de médecine de ville
qui était inondé de patients les
patients affluaient en quantité
d'ennemis février dans les cabinets de
médecine de ville alors pourtant que les
médecins n'étaient pas censés ans voire
avant la phase 3 qui a été déclenchée
début mars
bon je voudrais qu'on avance un tout
petit peu peut-être on va regarder un
petit infographie sur la cour de justice
de la république pour pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas à faire un peu de
pédagogie il ya quinze juges
c'est bien ça six députés et six
sénateurs sur trois magistrats de la
cour de cassation
oui alors il faut bien préciser que les
quinze sont élus les trois nations de
cassation a par leurs pairs et les
députés et les sénateurs c'est à la
proportionnelle des groupes dans les
titulaires que les suppléants ce qu'il
faut expliquer aussi c'est qu'on en est
qu'au tout début il ya un filtre
expliquez-nous ce à une commission des
requêtes oui à la cour de cassation qui
va transmettre ou non l'instruction il
ya un terroriste il ya un double filtre
ya une première commission qui la
commission des requêtes c'est à dire que
si un citoyen estime qu'un ministre a
fait une grave erreur qui lui a été
préjudiciable qui lui a causé un trouble
et bien il dépose un recours à un avocat
1 il dépose plainte devant la commission
des requêtes si la commission des
requêtes après avoir auditionné
les intéressés estime que y'a quand même
des cas graves
elle peut classer mais si c'est grave
elles transmettent à une deuxième
commission qu'est la commission
d'instruction ou la fièvre et la
commission d'instruction elle-même
examine la sphère et la transmet ou non
transparente comme d'ailleurs des mois
et des mois il faut quand même quand on
a eu le débat sur la loi de 93 on disait
il faut éviter que des centaines de
citoyens attac les ministres et qui soit
complètement en carafe et donc ce double
filtre est quand même protecteur pour
vraiment que ça soit en réalité vous
savez après on saisit la connaître après
deux dates les décennies à venir alors
par bateau je veux vraiment si vous
voulez coup faire comprendre que le
temps est uni on s'en plaint beaucoup du
temps judiciaire mais parfois le temps
judiciaire a une vertu c'est celui de la
vérité de l'émergence de la vérité il ne
faudrait pas dans cette affaire qu'on
ait une demi vérité il faut qu'on ait
une vérité qui prend le temps qui prend
le temps de l'émergence en fait surtout
surtout elle doit prendre le temps de
l'émergence qu'elle réalise peut-être
après la crise sanitaire par l'état
ingénieur quand elle doit jaillir c'est
le sait c'est le timing des magistrats
mais juste sur un point à propos du
filtre en fait en réalité si vous voulez
le filtre il existe toujours même dans
les juridictions ordinaires si vous
voulez saisir un juge d'instruction de
la matin vous pouvez vous constituer
partie civile et le juge d'instruction
décidera à l'issue de l'instruction s'il
doit ou non saisir la dernière précision
n'y a pas de partie civile on a la
courneuve et pas de parti justice de la
république
expliquez-nous ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire qu'en fait c'est pas les
plaignants n'ont pas la qualité de
partie ils ne peuvent pas interagir
ils ne peuvent pas demander d'acte il ne
veut pas pas demandé de dommages et
intérêt puisque ça il faudrait le faire
devant le tribunal administratif
ils ne peuvent pas si vous voulez être
parti se faire entendre pour faire
simple si on veut dire ça comme ses
victimes
on parle en raison des aides vont elles
ont besoin qualité de témoin devant
accor c'est très simple - sur lequel il
va y avoir de toutes façons une
amélioration une évolution
voilà qui richard est ailleurs alors en
pleine crise sanitaire ailleurs chez nos
voisins européens
il ya autant de procédures est ce qu'il
ya des plaintes similaires alors oui il
y en a et ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'elle ne tourne pas toujours ou
désavantages des politiques c'est à dire
que ce bras de fer peut aussi servir à
re légitimer les politiques qui à ce
moment là peuvent expliquer leur
position et expliqué leurs agissements
prenez l'italie par exemple je sais que
vous connaissez bien le dossier italien
giuseppe côté le président du conseil
italien et six de ses ministres avaient
été mises en cause et le parquet s'était
autosaisie n'a certain nombre de
plaintes notamment pour les décès dans
les maisons de retraite du nord de
l'italie
et bien cette première salve de plainte
le parquet a décidé de l'abandonner
il y a eu un classement sans suite parce
qu'elle était semble-t-il infondées il y
à d'autres cas qui sont à l'instruction
mais en tout cas pour l'instant vous
imaginez que ça re légitimer l'action
d'un premier ministre italien qui par
ailleurs pour l'instant a vu sa
popularité augmenter avec cette crise
un cas tout à fait différent mais qui
nous dit quand même quelque chose au
royaume uni les compagnies aériennes
british airways easyjet et ryanair ont
traduit en justice le gouvernement à
cause de la quarantaine imposée aux
voyageurs qui arrivait dans le pays
eh bien ça fait un énorme impact qu'est
ce qui s'est passé c'est que pendant ce
temps là les syndicats eux sont montés
au créneau sur le thème que les mêmes
compagnies étaient en train de licencier
énormément de personnel le premier
ministre boris johnson a saisi
l'occasion pour dire qu'il fallait pas
exagérer quand on voit de telles
compagnies traduire en justice son
gouvernement qu'elle ferait mieux garder
les employés
il a gagné cette bataille médiatique
dans un moment qui était difficile pour
lui et enfin un troisième exemple pedro
sanchez alors on voit bien le mélange
entre politique et justice
plus de 3000 familles attaque le
gouvernement espagnol toujours pour
cette question des maisons de retraite
dont on voit bien qu'elle est absolument
centrale est bien pour l'instant
dans les premières auditions pedro
sanchez et ses ministres ont fait valoir
qu'un certain nombre de leurs décisions
avaient été empêchés par les
gouvernements régionaux vous savez qu'en
espagne c'est un énorme sujet la
division avec les les régions eh bien ça
lui a permis aussi de re légitimer son
action sur le mode nous le gouvernement
central le gouvernement fédéral
on est utile en temps de crise et le
problème vient vient plutôt de la dia
passion la descente du rêveur non ils ne
doivent pas avoir peur de la justice
parce qu'ils peuvent aussi l'utiliser
pour légitimer leur action et trouvait
le reconstituer
qu'ils ont agi la député des français de
l'étranger que vous êtes très
intéressant c'est un moment intéressant
et moi je crois qu'il faut vraiment
garder à l'esprit aujourd'hui que le
plus intéressant c'est de voir qu'on a
encore une fois un système judiciaire
qui fonctionne un pays qui fonctionne
des instituts qui fonctionne et qui sont
là pour faire et pour établir des faits
responsabilité ou pas nous le verrons la
justice comme on dit classiquement fera
fera son travail se mettra à l ouvrage
mais je crois que c'est ça qu'il faut
renier ceux qui doit vraiment réjouir
nos concitoyens nous avons un système
des institutions qui fonctionnent qui
sont juste pour chacun d'entre eux est
un art pour conclure ce débat j'aimerais
vous faire réentendre le philosophe
alain finkielkraut qui s'exprimait sur
france inter ce temps plein de
confinement en mai dernier suivi de
l'avocat a rien limouxins qui était
invité sur sur ce plateau qui défend lui
aussi comme vous m un certain nombre de
dossiers pénaux mais lui dans la partie
pénale et non pas devant la cour de
justice de la république donc il ne
défend pas des anciens ministres ou des
ministres alain finkielkraut arié alimi
l'écouté aujourd'hui cet état que l'on
contrôle que l'on surveillait et que
l'on juge
eh bien on lui demande tout l'exécutif
pour eux est censé tout savoir tout
prévoir et tout pouvoir et donc les
retards deviennent des crimes
l'incertitude est niée et la tragédie
aussi et c'est ce qui fait qu'en effet
le vent mauvais du populisme pénal
souffle sur la france on est dans un
contexte ainsi institutionnelle très
particulier où il n'y a plus du tout de
contre-pouvoir où il ya eu un état
d'exception
pendant très longtemps où la justice est
en berne où le parlement est en berne
également et où il n'ya plus
d'expression démocratique faire le choix
de l'action judiciaire qu'elle soit
civile pénale ou administrative
c'est choisir le démocratie
contrairement à l'expression du
populisme pénal c'est choisir la
résolution pacifique d'une d'un conflit
et non pas la violence tellement à faire
un dernier tour de table pour réagir a
assez à ces deux positions complètement
opposées pour courir rapidement mène
d'abord je ne sais pas ce qu'elle
populistes ou pénales
je sais ce qu'est la justice pénale soif
de coupable ou yahoo qu'une soif de
coupable elle soit de vérité le
parlement exerce son office / 7 / la
responsabilité politique et comprendre
comment on a pu en arriver là
et la justice exerce son office pour
comprendre s'il ya eu une progrès et sur
dernier point sur monsieur halimi il ya
un point sur lequel je ne suis pas
d'accord je ne suis pas d'accord pour
dire que ce pays ne dispose pas de
contre-pouvoirs je ne suis pas d'accord
pour dire que le parlement est en berne
le parlement a fait l'office qui était
le sien alors je voudrais répondre mais
je voudrais d'abord vous entendre là
dessus allez on oublie que les
politiques ont quand même les moyens de
répondre
ils ont pris des actes en fonction d'un
certain nombre d'études en fonction
d'avis d'experts donc ils sont bien
outillés pour justifier leur décision
est l'une des vertus de la justice peut
être si le processus judiciaire suit
correctement son tour de leur permettre
de montrer que l'action a été efficace
et en tout cas que le but était de
sauver le maximum de gens dont moi je
crois aussi aux vertus d'une action
judiciaire
à condition bien évidemment qu'elle soit
médiatiquement contrôler parce qu'il ya
toujours le risque que pour faire
avancer une cause
on n'accuse plus que de raison hors des
tribunaux salle de corse en un mois
contre evian est en complet désaccord
avec les deux intervenants concernant ce
finalement ce qu'il dit est totalement
inexact c'est exactement l'inversé c'est
parce que le peuple aurait le sentiment
que des ministres ont fait des actes
tout à fait répréhensible et qu'ils ne
sont pas sanctionnés que on alimente le
populisme voilà donc c'est quand le
peuple se rend compte qu'il ya une
justice et que la justice tombe
eh bien il dit on a enfin une justice
notre pays
quand cet avocat qui défend la thèse que
ya plus de contre-pouvoirs il ya plus de
parlement on est toujours là moi j'ai
continué à à délibérer j'ai fait partie
des 25 premiers puisque nous étions 25
au début on a voté trois textes
successifs et on a on n'a pas cessé
et d'ailleurs c'est l'un des points sur
lequel
nous étions beaucoup battu pour dire le
parlement n'est pas en vacances fait d'y
aller très rapidement parce qu'on est
très en retard sur une enquête
parlementaire également et dont je
confirme qu'elle a fait son travail et
pour le coup je peux lui proposer un
certain nombre de pays dans lesquels il
n'y a pas de contre-pouvoirs il n'y a
pas d'état de droit il n'y a pas de
justice
la liste est longue et nous sommes ravis
d'être une démocratie merci merci
infiniment d'être venu sur ce plateau
débattre de ces questions comment les
députés réagissent aux annonces des
manuels macro et cette annonce choc de
couvre-feu dès 21h dans huit métropoles
c'est l'heure de ma journée à
l'assemblée n'est ce pas thomas oui
exactement marianne comme près de 23
millions de téléspectateurs hier soir
les députés ont eux aussi suivi
l'allocution d'emmanuel macron mais sont
ils satisfaits des annonces du président
on leur a posé la question
21h06 heures du matin le couvre feu qu'a
annoncé manuel macro hier c'est une
bonne mesure
alors c'est une mesure nécessaire pour
pouvoir protéger les françaises et les
français
on voit que les mesures qu'on a prises
jusqu'à présent sont pas suffisantes
dans ces métropoles
là on a pris des mesures simples qui
sont durs mais je crois que c'est hélas
la bonne décision il mieux vaut faire ça
maintenant que vous êtes dans une
situation catastrophique dans un mois ou
dans deux mois
c'est une situation qui n'est pas là par
hasard c'est une succession de deux
pièces causse après les masques après
les problèmes des tests après le
problème du traçage on a eu un secteur
de la santé qui a annoncé à 4000 lits de
réanimation supplémentaires il y en a
pas est ce que cette annonce n'est pas
signe de l'échec du gouvernement à avoir
réussi déconfinement c'est pas l'échec
du gouvernement c'est l'échec de la
population en général et je regarde les
autres pays et je me dis que en fait ça
a été un peu partout pareil alors ces
déclarations elles font presque
l'unanimité vous l'avez vu au sein des
députés mais certains regrettent
toutefois la place qui est laissée au
parlement dans les annonces c'est le cas
notamment du groupe socialiste ils ont
écrit au premier ministre pour lui
demander de venir s'exprimer ici à
l'assemblée devant la représentation
nationale
bonjour à léry rabot avec votre collègue
patrick kanner vous avez écrit un
courrier au premier ministre pour quoi
bien coûter vu les annonces du président
a répliqué hier soir qui instaure un
couvre feu mais quand même normal que
nous puissions lui poser des questions
qu'ils puissent nous
donner de l'information encore une fois
tout le mode d'emploi qui est prévu pour
ce couvre-feu dire qu'il ya des points
sur lesquels nous pouvons le dire nous
sommes d'accord pas d'accord et lui
poser des questions ça part et ça paraît
être fonctionnement normal d'une
démocratie ça se fait dans tous les
autres pays a pas de raison que ça se
passe pas en france personnellement s'il
y avait eu un débat j'aurais porté la
proposition d'un couvre-feu si je puis
dire en tout cas d'un semis confinement
à partir de 22 heures ce qui aurait
permis encore à la restauration et le
seul aurait permis au monde de la
culture qui a fait des efforts
considérables jusqu'à présent puisse
survivre
je vous rappelle que la politique
sanitaire c'est du ressort du
gouvernement et les français nous
reprocherait de ne pas prendre dans les
temps voulus les bonnes décisions
voilà mesdames on ne sait pas pour
l'heure si jean castex a prévu de venir
s'exprimer ici devant les députés à
l'assemblée mais une chose est sûre ils
pourront continuer de travailler au delà
de 21 heures y compris pendant le couvre
feu
ils seront considérés comme des
travailleurs de nuit merci beaucoup
thomas on va parler à présent d'un sujet
qui inquiète de plus en plus de familles
l'avenir des jeunes dans cette société
du coc vie de couvre feu nocturne est
une mauvaise nouvelle de plus pour on en
parle tout de suite avec nos invités
[Musique]
bonsoir isabelle florennes merci d'être
sur ce plateau est député modem des
hauts-de-seine bienvenue à vous paloma
moritz bonsoir vous êtes journaliste et
vous avait confondé l'association mieux
voter vous êtes aussi rédactrice en chef
vous me disiez tout ça hors antenne pour
inciter d'un magazine en ligne
c'est un mouvement qui s'appelle on est
prêt sur les réseaux sociaux les
questions écologiques sensibilise la
jeunesse sur les questions
environnementales et bienvenue sur ce
plateau yanis l'imam bonsoir vous êtes
vice président de la fage c'est le
premier syndicat étudiant de france je
vous donne la parole dans un instant on
a voulu prendre un peu la température au
lendemain de cette annonce choc c'est
couvre-feu dans huit métropoles et
partout en ile de france comment
réagissent ti donc c'est promener du
côté de la cité universitaire dans le
14e arrondissement
c'est un reportage de nathalie guillois
et de maïté frémont on en parle juste
après comme tous les étudiants de france
samuel 25 ans a appris qu'ils auraient à
subir un couvre-feu dès samedi
mais c'était étudiant américain est
plutôt philosophe
alors pour moi ces nouvelles règles sont
pas trop lourdes c'est juste triste et
déprimant et ça montre la situation
actuelle du monde
en fait dans cette cité universitaire de
paris 6800 jeunes de 140 nationalités se
côtoient en temps normal mais depuis la
rentrée avec les nouvelles restrictions
c'est la déception pour jean baptiste et
jérémy pour ces futurs ingénieurs
ce n'est pas vraiment la vie étudiante
rêver on a très bien ternes actions avec
les erasmus je connais pas encore
d'étudiants et je trouvais ça dommage
parce qu'on pouvait revivre une ambiance
auberge espagnole
on peut pas exister à cause du coville
salaces et je vous avoue
je suis beaucoup peiné mais on avance
mandat d'occasions de rencontrer des
gens tout simplement de décompresser
après les cours et autres pains
autrement qu'en faisant du sport par
exemple en étant isolées
du coup bah je sais pas trop comment ça
va évoluer mais on va voir si moralement
sera difficile ou non et le couvre-feu
de 21h à 6h du matin ne va pas améliorer
ce nouveau mode de vie les trois
étudiants vivent ici sur le campus mais
fini pour eux les soirées chez les uns
ou chez les autres
romuald le dit dès samedi ils se
tiendront à 6 par chambre c'est sûr
qu'on a beaucoup moins de liberté que
les autres années à paris enfin même
dans toutes les grandes villes de france
mais enfin moi je me sens pas sacrifier
quoi je comprends les mesures qui sont
prises et sûrement que à la place du
président j'avais peut-être pris les
mêmes donc franchement non enfin je
comprends évidemment on regrette un peu
notre année mais
on vit avec ça serait on a déjà
tellement davantage ce serait ça serait
vraiment mesquin de
critiquer ce à quoi au delà de ce
nouveau mode de vie imposées c'est
surtout la question de leur futur qui
s'est écrite aujourd'hui en pointe il
je sais pas si notre diplôme cette année
aura la même valeur que celui d'une
autre année est ce que nos diplômes vont
pas être dévalué sur le marché du
travail qui hérisse déjà d'être plus
compliqué peut-être dans certains
secteurs
enfin est ce qu'on est sûr que on pourra
bien s'intégrer dans le monde du travail
de demain alors y aller seul et même
vous avez évidemment écouter le
président hier on entend ces jeunes et
ils ont l'air plutôt à pacy a triste
état de la situation ils refusent cette
expression génération sacrifiée mais est
ce que vous êtes d'accord avec emmanuel
macron avoir 20 ans aujourd'hui c'est
dur je pense que oui aujourd'hui avoir
20 ans et c'est peut-être pas la
meilleure époque pour avoir vingt ans
n'est giguère dabach 20 en 2020 fêter
les mots précis du président je pense
que ces étudiants ils ont ils ont la
bonne réaction à la fois de dire qu'ils
sont peinés justement de se retrouver
dans cette situation là deux pas de
perdre le lien social 12 ans lui qui
fait une grande partie de la vie
étudiante mais de la même façon ils sont
résignés ils savent que c'est des règles
que ces règles c'est des règles vont
devoir être appliquée et je pense que la
plupart des étudiants et des jeunes sont
dans cette conception a tourné un
étudiant voilà qui voit se débrouiller
un peu seul on a un peu d'air par les
parents mais pas tant que ça qu'est ce
que ça a changé qu'est-ce qu'on a perdue
avec cette crise sanitaire
concrètement à la fac déjà j'imagine que
la faconde % dans les amphis ça change
tout beaucoup de présence à la maison
yahia lien social pour nous c'est
quelque chose de très important et c'est
aujourd'hui comment est ce que les
étudiants les jeunes sortent un peu de
cet isolement dans lequel ils sont ils
n'ont été pendant confinement et on a pu
faire une étude au niveau de la fage qui
a montré que ces étudiants se sentent et
ce n'est pour eux pourquoi dans le
profil mais pour des personnes qui se
trouvent par exemple en distanciait dès
qu'ils vont passer finalement toute la
journée chez eux et qu'ils vont passer
toute la soirée chez eux aussi forcément
je pense qu'il va on va re développer ce
genre de symptômes un peu qu'avaient les
étudiants et ces jeunes qui était seul
et finalement pour t par exemple la cité
universitaire où il ya beaucoup
d'étudiants internationaux n'ont pas
forcément la chance de pouvoir se
côtoyaient entre on a peur nous notre
côté que ces étudiants là bas ils
tombent dans la solitude et il tombe box
et d'isolement c'est la pré carré
et aussi annulé le confinement est
maintenant c'est restrictions nocturne
et conduites dans un dans un petit 15
mètres carrés c'est dur yaya qui sont
dans la précarité étudiante qui est
aussi avec le couvre-feu notamment des
questions qui vont se poser sur les jobs
étudiants ou les jobs étudiants ont été
notamment sacrifier cet été puisqu'il y
en avait pas assez pour tous les goûts
tous les étudiants et tous les jeunes
bien sûr en présence en visio à la
maison c'est ça en télétravail aussi
mais ça fait que bas sur ces questions
là sur la question des ressources
financières c'est des questions qui se
posent aujourd'hui non travail pour
débloquer aussi pour que le gouvernement
mette aussi sur sur la table une
enveloppe pour ces étudiants qui sont
qui se trouve dans une grande précarité
et on fait des étudiants cette année
vont s'appauvrir de mon pauvre y croyez
à kehl quel indicateur on va venir sur
les mesures mais l'appauvrissement des
étudiants c'est quoi concrètement c'est
l'appauvrissement passé le fait que nous
en tout cas de la façon dont on arrive à
le voir c'est au niveau des dispositifs
d'être qu'on a mis en place pour ces
étudiants là pour les jeunes en général
qui bat touche de plus en plus de jeunes
et d'étudiants donc on voit qu'il ya une
augmentation justement de ces personnes
là qui souhaitent bénéficier de
dispositifs et au delà de ça les aides
qui sont des lacs rousset où ils vous y
restez l homme à maurice comment vous
pourriez nous décrire au fond le
quotidien le nouveau quotidien des
étudiants des jeunes dans l'ère du
président en france je pense que ce
quotidien il est profondément transformé
parce que il ressemble puis enfin je
vois par exemple moi même et j'ai une
petite soeur qui vient de rentrer à
l'université elle vit pas du tout les
maux rentrée universitaire comment il ya
quelque chose d'assez lourdes assez
pesant l'angoissent aussi sur l'avenir
j'imagine pas ce que l'avenir
professionnel semble vraiment plus
bouché aujourd'hui que ça pouvait l'être
il ya quelques mois il ya une angoisse
sur l'avenir professionnel mais je pense
qu'il ya une angoisse de façon générale
sur l'avenir du fait de l'urgence
environnementale dans laquelle on est et
beaucoup de ces jeunes en fait subi ce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui l'écho anxiété
c'est à dire cette cette anxiété
profonde de se dire qu'ils n'arrivent
pas à se projeter dans un monde
potentiellement à plus 7 degrés où on
est en train d'attendre des seuils de
bascule des points de non retour et
potentiellement il fera 50 degrés à
paris
en 2050 le climat le virus le terrorisme
on a vu frapper encore il n'ya pas
longtemps
isabelle florennes quel message vous
pouvez faire passer on a on a une série
de batteries mesure on va en parler mais
j'imagine que vous êtes mère de famille
peut-être que vos enfants ont un fils de
20 ans 20 ans voilà oui qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce qu'on ressent quand on voit
que voilà les portes se ferment l'avenir
se bouche alors il ya évidemment je suis
partagé le constat d'inquiétude et
d'angoissé sur l'avenir c'est sûr
vingt ans n'est pas un âge facile avec
une crise comme on la vit actuellement
et en même temps j'ai le sentiment que
pendant ces derniers mois on a vu aussi
beaucoup de jeunes faire preuve de
grande maturité et de grande
responsabilité
c'est aussi un constat voilà ils
entendent ils entendent beaucoup
et dire que c'est aussi de leur faute et
non de faits il faut arrêter autres
canadiens martin plante qu'un cas je le
dis on va pas commencer à d je connais
les appâts stigmatise génération un peu
peut-être des paroles ont été parfois
malheureuses moi c'est parce que j'ai
constaté
moi je compte j'ai constaté autour de
moi beaucoup de civisme des jeunes
effectivement qui ont pu se retrouver
mais qui ont pris leurs responsabilités
aussi de respecter le langage
gouvernemental c'est à dire tout
simplement en période sanitaires quand
on a des cas contacts ont respecté
procédure j'ai constaté que les jeunes
comme les comme les autres était bon
c'est vrai qu'il est conscient et bien
responsable quand plus maintenant ce qui
est des choses différentes par rapport à
d'autres générations ils sont hyper
connectés alors cette hyper connexion on
en connaît les désavantages aussi en
tant que parent mais on peut en
connaître les avantages en période de
crise je crois qu aussi pour rompre à
certaines parties d'isolement ils l'ont
tous vécu avec le confinement mais ils
vont le revivre quelque part pour ceux
qui sont concernés par par le couvre-feu
je pense que les réseaux sociaux je
pense que nous tous les outils dont elle
est ce qu'on peut permettre sérieusement
de les laisser et de l'est et de
continuer à les mettre en contact avec
leurs amis leurs communautés je pense
que c'est là le numérique devient
langage et bien sûr le numérique devient
le lieu le lieu du du livre en forme et
le confinement nocturne le couvre feu
c'est terrible pour les amenons c'est
terrible pour les jeunes oui toujours
sur des questions de lien social et de
vie étudiante c'est sûr que ça va ça
profondément et c'est ce qui était un
peu dit dans le reportage juste avant
bah ça fait que des gens se rencontrent
eux ne se rencontreront pas et salons
des annuités qui vont pas forcément être
le fait d'être vécue aussi comme
propagateur du virus pas forcément
malades
et ça par contre je suis très heureux
d'entendre ces propos là de dire qu on
voit des jeunes ont respecté des
gestes-barrières parce qu'aujourd'hui on
a été énormément mis sur le devant de la
scène comme étant ben voilà des jeunes
sont les personnes qui qui est si font
circuler le virus alors que pas plus
qu'une autre d'autres générations d'âge
là c'est vraiment je trouve ça
intéressant qu'on arrête un peu de
culpabiliser toujours les jeunes parce
que finalement c'est dans cette posture
là que beaucoup de personnes nous ont
commis les jeunes pour dire ben voilà
c'est une catégorie d'âge comme les
autres et qu'on respecte les règles
comme comme les autres maires sont les
étudiants les réponses qui sont sur la
table
hier 150 euros en plus pour les
bénéficiaires des apl là c'est pas pour
les étudiants mais pour le pour les
bénéficiaires du rsa également mais déjà
est-ce que c'est suffisant est ce que
les aides aux étudiants sont suffisantes
aujourd'hui en général non les aides
sociales pour les étudiantes elles sont
aujourd'hui insuffisante et que ce soit
au niveau des bourses sur critères
sociaux ou non on demande justement une
certaine libéralisation de celle ci pour
voir aussi leur montant augmenter l
entendement depuis longtemps mais
aujourd'hui et depuis un an la précarité
étudiante avait mis sur le devant de la
scène entre les événements qui en
novembre dernier à lyon et tout et tout
ce qui s'est passé sur la période du coc
vide on voit qu'aujourd'hui et sa limite
sur le devant de la scène qu'il ya des
étudiants qui ne peuvent pas manger à
leur faim des jeunes et des étudiants
qui peuvent pas manger à leur faim
donc comment est-ce que nous aujourd'hui
en tant qu'organisation m on a travaillé
là dessus on a mis en place des
dispositifs mais c'est pas des
dispositifs qui sont structurels
aujourd'hui ce qu'on demande c'est qu'il
des vraies politiques structurelles au
niveau des étudiants et des jeunes pour
les sortir de cette précarité d'ascq
iliad à côté des étudiants qui ont une
bourse mais qui font peuvent pas
forcément vivre et de l'autre côté des
jeunes est sûre c'est sur ce plan là
entre guillemets nous ce qu'on demande
et quelque chose qu'on nous refuse aussi
qui n'avance pas dans les négociations
c'est l'ouverture du rsa pour les 18 25
ans c'est quelque chose qui nous paraît
aujourd'hui avec beaucoup d'autres
acteurs et partenaires sociaux être
quelque chose qui avec lauren ça c'est
vrai que ça a étonné beaucoup
le président n'a pas voulu dire oublier
cette mesure on le regrettait jeu je
pense que le
le premier ministre et le gouvernement
en tête une reconfiguration du plan
pauvreté pour s'adapter justement à la
crise et à la situation des jeunes donc
sur la question du rsa je pense qu'il
m'aime ça monte ça les bénéficiaires et
notamment les plus jeunes mais nous
attendons des mesures et j'espère est en
tout cas un certain nombre de
parlementaires
interroge le gouvernement toutes les
semaines sur sur ces sujets là non je
pense pas parce que je j'ai cru
comprendre que dans les jours prochains
des mesures fortes notamment en termes
de de revenu universel qui pourront
toucher des catégories notamment plus
jeunes pourraient être en tout cas
envisagé annoncé donc moi j'attends et
nous attendons et nous sommes nombreux à
d attendre des mesures de type plus
universel qui pourrait suivant des
critères toucher et notamment des
publics plus jeunes c'est des choix qui
doivent être faits par les politiques
pour revenir sur les jeunes et la
précarité étudiante est quand même eu
des mesures notamment sur les repas
d'abaissement de repas étudiants très
récemment je le tiens on sait très bien
que il va y aller cette précarité à
augmenter pas du fait que les petits
jobs malheureusement les compléments de
revenus n'existe plus actuellement pour
la plupart de ces jeunes il ya aussi un
effort effectivement je crois envisagé
sur la question des bourses mais ça je
n'ai pas d'informations en ce sens pour
le moment paloma maurice
cette prise de conscience des jeunes au
fond de difficultés mais ça peut être
aussi un sursaut comment elle va se
traduire à votre avis dans les mois qui
viennent est-ce qu'il peut y avoir une
forme de radicalisation de la jeunesse
ou au contraire un mouvement un
mouvement politique
il ya un slogan de mai 68 que j'ai
retrouvé récemment qui dit une société
qui abolit toute aventure fait de
l'abolition de cette société la seule
aventure possible et je pense en fait
que les jeunes en vie aujourd'hui de
s'embarquer dans cette aventure là et
sont de plus en plus en train de
questionner un système en fait est
abolie qui créait l'égalité qui qui ne
répond pas en fait à l'urgence
environnementale qui créent des systèmes
d'oppression en fait notamment entre les
êtres sur le vivant sur les questions du
patriarcat du féminisme de l'antiracisme
état est en fait le plus en parler d'une
forme d'engagement ou de radicalisation
en fait il serait ce d'être violente
maintenant ce n'est pas ce n'est pas une
fin mais en fait la radicalité c'est de
prendre un problème à sa source et en
fait je pense qu'aujourd'hui les jeunes
ont entre sont en train de réaliser le
fait que tout est lié et que donc s'ils
veulent avoir un changement il faut
qu'il questionne un système entier est
en même temps c'est une aventure
formidable comme je disais puisque tout
est à réinventer et évidemment qu'il ya
un degré de radicalité qui est en train
de monter parce qu'il ya de l'autre côté
en degré de radicalité qui est en train
de monter puisque il ya les réponses en
fait face à ces problèmes là n'existe
pas aujourd'hui les inégalités ont
jamais été aussi forte et on voit bien
par exemple les français pour beaucoup
je sais pas ce que j'ai vu il ya une
étude qui est sorti à deux destins
communs ya un mois qui s'appelle les
oubliés de la pandémie qui est très
intéressante et qui dit qu'en fait la
plupart des français considèrent que le
gouvernement n'est pas à la hauteur de
l'urgence environnementale et à côté de
ça pense que cette crise sanitaire est
un moment important pour apporter des
changements au pays et donc en fait
quand on voit par exemple la réponse du
gouvernement à la convention citoyenne
pour le climat dont les mesures sont de
plus en plus détricotée etc
oui il ya une forme de radicalité à dire
là là ce n'est plus possible il ya en
fait simplement un refus un moment où la
jeunesse et je pense en fait la
population en général dit non dit stop
et dit nous on veut un autre un autre
horizon possible on veut que vous nous
montrez défis en tout cas je sais pas si
ça va se traduire dans une forme de
radicalité politique violente mais il ya
1 ou peut-être qui est en train de se
constituer de face ou plus plus forte
qu'avant face à toutes ces difficultés
vous partager cette analyse
on dit que cette génération si elle
n'est pas sacrifiée avec plus politique
qu'avant plus idéologique c'est
important aujourd'hui de repolitiser
justement les jeunes et de faire en
sorte qu'ils prennent
de conscience de leur destin et c'est là
où je rejoins totalement fin ce qui a
été dit ces cui c'est important de
remettre la politique au coeur au coeur
de la jeunesse aussi parce
qu'aujourd'hui que ce soit en termes de
programmes électoraux ou des politiques
qui sont menées pour la jeunesse on est
finalement très beau consulter et les
jeunes votent peu sur les échances sur
exigence démocratique malheureusement et
c'est aussi notre travail à nous de
repolitiser en informant sensibilisant
sur ces questions là pour permettre
finalement pas que juste ou dans l'est
dans les programmes dans les politiques
qu'ils soient prises en compte qu'ils
soient faites en fait finalement on est
réellement une prise en compte de la
jeunesse et des enjeux de la jeunesse
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas forcément
pas le cas aujourd'hui
le paquet a été mis sur l'apprentissage
sur le travail des jeunes ya énormément
de mesures aujourd'hui un employeur a
énormément des daims plusieurs milliers
de lots d'euros pour pour un apprenti
pour la première embauche et c'est pas
cette prise de conscience pas que vous
attendez à les y aident à jeunesse et il
ya des débats il ya des mesures qui ont
été faites pour la jeunesse et ça c'est
certain que ce soit dans le plan de
relance ou alors des as traduit mais
aujourd'hui quand un gouvernement met en
avant et en chef de file un peu le s est
nul comme étant quelque chose comme la
première politique publique qu'ennemi
finalement todd de proue des politiques
de jeunesse et qui finalement leed un
peu pas mal de choses sur ces questions
là aussi en termes d'éducation populaire
en termes de en termes de valeurs de la
république je pense qu'il ya un réel
souci aussi là dessus qu'il faut crever
il avait le mot de la fin
quel message voulez leur faire passer
vous les entendez comment ça peut se
traduire concrètement quand même de
d'optimisme même si on est dans une
période d'incertitude
pour ces jeunes c'est vrai que c'est un
moment difficile à passer pour toute la
société pour tout le monde et pour
toutes les catégories
moi je crois quand même qu'il ont ils
ont des atouts en main que le
gouvernement y est je pense le président
de la république en a conscience et il
l'a dit hier et je pense que c'est pas
faim dans ses mots c'est une réelle
prise de conscience depuis le début
c'est pour ça que juste pour revenir sur
la question de la principe de
l'apprentissage ce gouvernement depuis
le début et moi personnellement en tant
que député j'y crois la résorption du
chômage des jeunes par la formation par
l'alternance et d'un des meilleurs
moyens pour sauver une partie en tout
cas entraîné une partie de la jeunesse
vert du meilleur en tout cas on va
suivre ce dossier de près parce que ça
ne fait que commencer et que l'avenir
est devant vous merci beaucoup d'être
venu sur le plateau de lcp c'est la fin
de cette émission merci à vous de
m'avoir suivi tout de suite votre soirée
documentaire à demain
[Musique]